merci d'être avec nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure et l'une des Hauts-de-Seine
mange du groupe les républicains
vice-président du Sénat on va évidemment
parler de la locution d'Emmanuel Macron
ce soir à 20h il a raison de s'exprimer
c'est le bon moment quel message il peut
délivrer
je ne sais pas ce qu'il a décidé de de
donner comme orientation à son propos
c'est un peu compliqué moi j'aurais
pensé imaginer qu'il allait attendre un
petit peu d'abord pour voir quand même
un peu comment se passait le mouvement
jeudi et ensuite comment les contacts
parce qu'il y a quand même des contacts
entre l'exécutif et les syndicats
avancer ces jours-ci voilà est-ce que
c'est trop tôt n'en sais rien il voulait
absolument prendre la parole
immédiatement après la promulgation bon
s'il a des choses particulières à dire
tant mieux si c'est juste pour dire la
page retraite est derrière nous
m'apporter tout verte il faut maintenant
accélérer les réformes ce sera un coup
pour rien vous croyez que ce soit ça
j'ai un peu peur vu un petit peu
l'évolution de ces dernières semaines
j'ai un petit peu peur que
l'exécutif considère que les retraites
passent déjà par profiser perte et qu'on
est déjà à l'étape suivante c'est vrai
juridiquement le texte est promulgué il
est promulgué ça n'est pas vrai
politiquement et socialement parce que
le pays reste extrêmement divisé et quel
que soit les textes futurs on nous parle
d'un grand texte travail il faut
forcément du lien avec les syndicats du
dialogue social est-ce que ça peut être
rétabli tout de suite je ne le crois pas
donc ça rend les choses compliquées pour
la suite et le lien avec les Français il
peut le renouer ce soir
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué et puis
je sais pas si parce que si c'est pour
dire effectivement ce soir voilà je
devais le faire c'est fait nous passons
aux étapes suivantes ça suffira pas les
Français ont été quand même très
atteints en revanche moi j'attends
peut-être de lui qui disent écouter
franchement ça m'a pas fait plaisir de
faire cette réforme parce que demander
aux gens de travailler deux ans de plus
ça ne fait plaisir à personne on n'est
pas dans un milieu où ça aide on sait
très bien que c'est un sacrifice que
cette un effort et on aurait préféré que
pendant toute cette période ils disent
pourquoi il fallait faire cet effort et
le justifier le légitimer et pas
seulement dire c'est comme ça on passe à
64 ans pour sauver le système d'accord
mais enfin une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
fait un peu juste dans une tribune au
Journal du Dimanche le vice-président de
votre partie Julia Robert lui plaît
pourra refaire un homme dit que c'est le
seul le retour au peuple peut évacuer la
pression sociale qui s'est accumulée
pour vous je n'y crois pas je n'y crois
pas alors il y a il y avait déjà une
première demande de référendum
d'initiative populaire qui était rejeté
par le Conseil on verra ce qu'est la
deuxième demande qui serait examinée le
3 mai je n'y crois pas je pense que
d'abord par définition le temps d'avoir
les signatures le temps de le mettre en
place ça fera un référendum au mieux au
mieux à la fin de l'année voir début
2024 c'est extrêmement loin on va pas
rester huit mois neuf mois uniquement
dans une position attentiste à ne rien
faire en attendant référendum donc je
n'y crois pas soit c'était une volonté
de l'exécutif initial et il y avait un
référendum immédiat soit il y a pas
cette volonté et je ne crois pas
beaucoup au RIP parce que on aurait pu
imaginer je l'avais dit moi il y a déjà
4-5 mois on aurait pu imaginer de dire
aux Français voilà soit on passe de 62 à
64 soit par exemple on passe de 35
heures à 38 heures c'est à dire plus de
travail chaque année et peut-être
il y avait pas de nécessité de passer de
62 à 64 ce débat n'a jamais eu lieu
vraiment jamais c'est dommage
nous nous avions dit il faut d'abord un
grand texte travail sur le partage de la
valeur sur l'amélioration des salaires
sur la modification du regard des
Français par rapport au travail et
ensuite un texte sur les retraites on
nous a d'abord présenté le texte sur les
retraites et maintenant on nous parle
éventuellement d'un texte sur le travail
sauf que le lien est coupé Laurent
Berger appelle à casser la baraque en
nombre de manifestants le 1er mai est-ce
que vous redoutez cette journée est-ce
que pourvu un risque de radicalisation
si c'est une manifestation massive mais
bien encadrée comme les syndicats savent
le faire il y a pas de problème la
liberté d'expression existe le droit de
manifester constitutionnel il n'y a pas
de souci il faut pas que ça
oui oui je pense que l'expression sera
supérieure au premier mais classique
mais pour autant est-ce que ça aura un
impact sur la réforme des retraites ou
sur la suite des réformes je n'en sais
rien elle dit qu'elle veut accélérer les
réformes c'est ce qu'on dit pour vous on
a un peu le sentiment que ils sont tous
sur le thème de dire allez la page
retraite on veut même plus en entendre
parler on va vous parler d'autre chose
sauf que bon pour le moment on nous a
retiré par exemple ici le texte
immigration le texte justice on nous
parle d'un texte travail mais à mon avis
pas avant juillet c'est-à-dire en
réalité pas avant les élections
sénatoriales donc voilà d'un côté on
nous dit on veut tourner la page
retraite de l'autre côté on vide
l'agenda parlementaire alors il faut
savoir ce que ça veut dire accélération
des réformes on va parler du fond de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
est-ce que pour vous Emmanuel Macron a
eu raison de promulguer la loi aussi
rapidement après cette décision
je pense que si les syndicats avaient
accepté son invitation à venir demain et
ils ont dit dès vendredi qu'il ne
viendrait pas il lui fallut qu'il
attendent de voir les syndicats demain
et ne pas promulguer avant à partir du
moment où les syndicats dit non on ne
viendra pas avant le premier mai comme
c'était à plus de 15 jours du texte donc
le délai de promulgation pour le
Président il n'avait en réalité pas le
choix de toute façon l'utile promulgué
d'un vendredi ou aujourd'hui ou
après-demain ça ne changeait rien
puisque aurait pas eu de contact avec
les syndicats donc c'est pas une erreur
et en tout cas quand j'entends dire que
il l'a fait nuit Taman c'est l'heure de
parution du Journal officiel il sait pas
levé à 3h du matin pour promulguer le
texte pour embêter le monde mais bon ça
vous a surpris cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ou c'est conforme à ce
que vous attendiez non c'était
totalement conforme on pensait bien
qu'il n'annulerait pas l'ensemble du
texte sur la procédure
je vous rappelle que dans les PLFSS dans
les projets de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale précédent il y avait
des amendements du groupe LR passant à
64 ans et le Conseil constitutionnel n'a
jamais annulé les PLFSS en disant ça
c'est pas dans un PLFSS donc
la logique était qu'il valide la
procédure en revanche il y avait un
doute y compris pour nous d'ailleurs sur
un certain nombre de d'éléments que nous
avions voté notamment sur le contrat
senior je regrette qu'ils étaient
annulés mais bon ils peuvent être remis
dans un texte travail quelques éléments
restent quand même par exemple les
amendements mère de famille si je puis
dire cela n'ont pas été annulé on va en
parler on va voir tout ça puisque
effectivement le Sénat va apporter
plusieurs modifications à cette réforme
initiale alors que sont-elles devenues
ont-elles passées la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel on va ça avec ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Roger
de droites du Sénat dans cette réforme
des retraites
du Sénat à cette réforme des retraites a
été retoquée par le Conseil
constitutionnel il s'agissait de
l'expérimentation d'un CDI senior un
contrat sans cotisation familiale pour
inciter les entreprises à embaucher des
salariés de plus de 60 ans les sages du
Conseil constitue constitutionnel pardon
estimé que ce CDI senior est bien
n'avait rien à faire dans un budget de
la Sécurité sociale rectificatif un coup
dur pour les sénateurs les républicains
un coup dur qui n'a pas échappé à
l'opposition de gauche du Sénat regardez
ce que dit le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat Patrick Kanner dans
un article de notre site public sénat.fr
je le cite les républicains ne doivent
pas être fiers d'avoir servi de
marionnettes qui est le marionnettiste
c'est le président de la République et
les marionnettes ce sont les LR qui se
sont retrouvés censurés aujourd'hui ils
ont prétexté que leur soutien au 64 ans
était équilibré par ses cavaliers
sociaux ce sont eux des arroseurs
arrosés on va vous faire réagir Roger
carotum mais malgré tout Alex certains
apports du Sénat ont été conservés dans
le texte ah oui on peut aussi regarder
le vert à moitié plein puisque trois
mesures importantes ajoutées au texte
lors du débat au Sénat ont été conservés
après à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel notamment la surcote de
5% des pensions de retraite des maires
de famille si elles ont tout leur
trimestres à 63 ans et qu'elles
acceptent de travailler jusqu'à 64 pour
les carrières longues le Sénat a voté a
permis à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 20 et 21 ans de pouvoir
partir à 63 ans départ anticipées
également pour les personnes en
incapacité permanente elles pourront
toujours partir à 60 ans noter aussi que
le Sénat avait voté un malus sur la
pension de retraite d'un parent qui
serait condamné pour maltraitance envers
son enfant ainsi qu'une pension de
réversion pour les enfants qui
deviennent orphelins ça ça reste dans le
texte Roger carotc le CDI senior retoqué
c'est un coup dur ou vous étiez préparé
on était préparé parce que pendant le
débat le gouvernement nous avait dit
d'ailleurs qu'il était défavorable à la
mesure en affirmant que ça n'était pas
sa place si je puis dire et qu'il
fallait intégrer ça éventuellement dans
un texte travail moi je considère que
les mesures qui ont été conservées sont
déjà des mesures importantes le CDI
senior en y reviendra si un texte
travail on le représentera et cette
fois-ci on se sera valide puisque le
Conseil constitutionnel ne dit pas que
la mesure en elle-même est
inconstitutionnelle il dit c'est pas
dans un texte sur les retraites qu'il
faut le mettre donc c'est autre chose et
donc on y reviendra pour le reste être
traité de marionnettes par le président
du groupe socialiste c'est assez comment
dire tasser surnaturel enfin bon il est
clair que faire son travail de sénateur
améliorer la loi c'est le travail de
tous les sénateurs et qu'on soit ensuite
censuré ou pas par le conseil c'est
autre chose mais moi je préfère qu'on
fasse le travail comme on l'a toujours
fait au Sénat ça nous distingue
tellement de l'Assemblée nationale
alors le CDI senior est l'index seniors
ont été retoqués de ce texte ça veut
dire qu'au final bien la question très
importante de l'emploi des seniors n'a
pas été traité pour l'instant dans cette
réforme des retraites c'est très clair
c'est pour ça que nous étions me
demandeurs à vrai dire nous étions
demandeurs d'un texte travail parlant
notamment des seniors avant la réforme
des retraites bon c'est comme ça ça n'a
pas été fait nous nous espérons et nous
sommes toujours disponibles pour
travailler sur un grand texte au travail
sur l'emploi des seniors sur les
carrières longues sur le partage de la
valeur qui aujourd'hui est clairement
défavorable aux salariés et qui doit
être modifié ça n'est pas acceptable de
voir alors que les difficultés sociales
sont ce qu'elles sont que des gens
travaillent en leur demande de
travailler plus et on voit d'un côté des
bénéfices parfois faramineux de
certaines entreprises du CAC 40 et des
salaires qui ne progressent pas il doit
y avoir une modification du partage de
la valeur en revanche est-ce que vous
diriez que la situation a des femmes a
été un peu améliorée dans notre
situation du régime des retraites avec
cette surcote pour les maires de
là-dessus le Conseil n'a pas censuré
cette mesure et c'est très bien
5%, ça peut paraître modeste si on peut
faire plus dans un autre texte on fera
plus mais je pense que c'est une
amélioration sensible oui on vous
souhaitez on l'a compris que ces mesures
soient réintégrées dans un texte travail
vous êtes Optim
iste le fait que ce texte travaille pour
le jour rapidement c'est possible vu
l'état de la relation les syndicats
c'est-à-dire que quand on nous dit on
nous avait dit peut-être au mois de juin
ou en juillet ça me paraît bien court
parce qu'il faut quand même beaucoup de
concertation avec les syndicats avant je
vois pas les choses se faire là on est
déjà fait avril donc mais en revanche un
texte travail un peu un peu travaillé
pour de bon cette fois-ci et un peu
intégré pourquoi pas en octobre novembre
si on peut le voter avant la fin de
l'année c'est très bien
avant avant l'été je n'y crois pas mais
avant la fin de l'année pour être
applicable début 2024 ce serait bien
vous avez été mise des relations avec le
Parlement Roger est-ce que cette réforme
des retraites pour vous a casser quelque
chose entre l'exécutif et le Parlement
oui dans la mesure où elle a été mal
gérée je parle même plus du fond du
texte le 64 ans le 43 43 ans nuité nous
étions plutôt favorables mais elle a été
mal gérée d'abord parce que je l'ai dit
il lui fallut un texte travail avant
pour changer un peu la donne avant de
voir comment on travaillait plus déjà
travailler mieux travailler pour gagner
plus et après on pouvait vous regarder
si on pouvait travailler plus mais bon
on a inversé les choses premier point
deuxième point
ça a été mal géré dans le lien entre les
groupes politiques et l'exécutif voilà
on peut vous savez quand moi j'ai
conduit la réforme de la Constitution en
même s'ils n'ont pas voté cette réforme
je voyais régulièrement le groupe
socialiste de l'Assemblée le groupe
socialiste du Sénat je voyais
régulièrement les oppositions pour
vraiment essayer de trouver des
compromis essayer d'avancer une réforme
des retraites
c'est évidemment la réforme type qui
doit être consensuelle avec les
syndicats comme avec les groupes
politiques et ça n'a pas été fait pour
vous est-ce que il faut réformer les
institutions selon vous
en tout cas les institutions pour le
moment protègent beaucoup l'exécutif
donc je propose que l'exécutif y aille
d'une main tremblante merci
à tout à l'heure on parlera justement
DLR quelles options politiques dans
cette crise
avec vous Roger caoutchi merci Alex hier
sur BFM TV vous l'avez entendu Xavier
Bertrand infirmé que s'il arrivait au
pouvoir en 2027 il remettrait la réforme
des retraites sur le métier la jugeant
profondément injuste vous comprenez
cette position
je l'entends puisqu'il était opposé au
texte je l'entends mais pas très faim je
n'y crois guère vous savez en 2010 quand
il y a eu la réforme Sarkozy Fillon
passant de 60 à 62 ans toutes les
oppositions et notamment le groupe
social les groupes socialistes on dit
alors ça si en 2012 donc deux ans après
on gagne on balaye là la réforme ils
sont arrivés au pouvoir en 2012 avec
François Hollande pendant 5 ans on a
plus entendu parler de rien la réforme a
été maintenue on est même allé plus loin
puisque c'est pendant le mandat de
François Hollande que la réforme
Touraine prévoyait 43 annuités donc
voilà je pense que ce qu'on dit là sous
le coup de l'émotion de la pression
dans quatre ans
je n'en suis pas sûr et c'est surtout
pas la position officielle des
républicains est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a une scission dans votre
famille politique sur ça
normal sur un sujet aussi lourd il y a
des gens qui disaient qu'ils étaient
pour qu'ils étaient pour la réforme
c'était la grande majorité des LR il y a
des gens qui étaient plus nuancés en
disant mais pourquoi mettre une question
d'âge mets ton 43 à nuités mais pas
d'âge d'autres qui étaient opposés pour
s'opposer à Emmanuel Macron de manière
politique plus globale donc c'est normal
dans une formation politique qui est des
tensions après il faut pas que ces
tensions deviennent division et c'est le
cas est-ce que elle est-ce que cette
forme de retraite finalement elle a mis
en lumière de lignes au sein de votre
partie une vraie fracture non elle a pas
mis en lumière une vraie fracture elle a
mis en lumière le fait qu'il fallait
travailler différemment entre le groupe
de l'Assemblée le groupe du Sénat
premier point et à l'intérieur du groupe
du Sénat du de l'Assemblée plutôt à
l'intérieur du groupe de l'assemblée il
faut qu'il y ait peut-être plus de
cohésion par rapport à un texte parce
que c'est vrai que ça n'a pas donné
l'image il faut le dire d'un groupe
républicain uni par rapport au texte
c'est ce qu'il voulait voter le texte
est-ce que ils sont posés au 49-3 est-ce
qu'il votait la motion de censure ça a
été un peu confus voilà ça veut dire
quoi différemment entre l'Assemblée
il y a des liens réguliers il y a de la
concertation entre les présidents de
groupe et avec le président du Sénat
alors l'archer les choses se font mais
il faut que ce soit conclusif est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on trouve un autre moyen
de travailler entre le parti lui-même le
groupe du Sénat le groupe de l'Assemblée
comment faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de cohésion plus d'entraînement
collectif c'est difficile tant qu'on a
pas moi je le dis franchement tant qu'on
n'a pas fait savoir qui serait notre
candidat aux élections présidentielles
tant que vous n'avez pas un leader qui
prend la lumière parce qu'il est
candidat aux élections présidentielles
vous avez du mal
on voit bien le RN on voit Marine Le Pen
du côté de LFI bon même si c'est pas
décidé sur lui c'est quand même
Mélenchon qui prend la lumière du côté
de l'exécutif par définition Emmanuel
Macron ou les éventuels
potentiels candidats suivants nous pour
le moment on a rien décidé bah tant
qu'on a rien décidé on a du mal à
prendre la lumière voilà Éric Ciotti
semblait assez décider sur le nom de
Laurent Wauquiez c'est pas le cas
certains disent ben Laurent Wauquiez et
pendant toute cette réforme des
retraites on l'a pas beaucoup vu et à
droite on aime bien on aime bien les
bonaparcs sur le pont d'Arcole on n'aime
pas trop voilà donc c'est pas planqué
parce qu'il a dit ce qu'il avait à dire
mais beaucoup aurait souhaité qu'il
s'exprime davantage qui s'implique
davantage oui moi le premier je le
reconnais
il lui fallut qu'on est à ce moment-là
des voix forte qui portent oui est-ce
qu'il faut en accord de gouvernement
entre les républicains exécutif je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire
d'abord parce que pour avoir un accord
de gouvernement il faut être deux est-ce
que le Président de la République mettre
des horloges nous a proposé un accord de
gouvernement non on nous demande chaque
fois à nous est-ce que vous êtes pour un
accord de gouvernement mais qui nous l'a
proposé par les journalistes en tout cas
pas le président de la République
président de la République dit je veux
élargir la majorité c'est la mission que
j'ai confié à Elisabeth borne mais on
veut pas rentrer dans la majorité donc
si le président disait
éventuellement coalition cohabitation
cohabitation avec des parties qui sont
dans la majorité ou en dehors de la
majorité sur un projet sur des thèmes
précis immigration sécurité loi travail
peut-être qu'on pourrait commencer à
imaginer discuter tant que c'est juste
des dents jeunes gens de bonne famille
venait donc renforcé ma majorité non
mais c'est un changement de cas oui avec
un Premier ministre issu de vos rangs
si un changement de cap et un changement
de politique c'est autre chose mais
est-ce que le président de la République
le souhaite et vous
un peu que le Président de la République
change de cap oui je le souhaite après
comme on en est pas là on va éviter de
sauter les étapes parce que ça ne sert à
rien tant que Présidente c'est pas
exprimé moins que ce soit il nous
annonce que finalement mais à coule pas
il va changer de politique mais vous y
croyez non vous en doutez
on va terminer par l'actualité dans
votre région on va aller voir Jacques
paquet et directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris bonjour Jacques
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on va
parler d'un autre sujet avec vous on va
parler des transports et
particulièrement de l'avenir du
périphérique parisien
tout à fait tout à fait parce que c'est
aujourd'hui que que s'ouvre monsieur
carochi que s'ouvre l'enquête publique
jusqu'au 28 mai organisé par la mairie
de Paris sur la pérennisation de ce
qu'on appelle la voix olympique
c'est-à-dire que vous le savez pendant
les Jeux Olympiques il y a la voie de
gauche dans les deux sens du
périphérique sera réservé aux athlètes
et aux VIP et la mairie de Paris
souhaite que cette réservation qui sera
réservée aux véhicules accueillant plus
de deux personnes c'est pour favoriser
le covoiturage soit pérenniser au-delà
des Jeux Olympiques
j'allais dire tout le temps et les
contrevenants s'exposant à une amende de
135 euros je crois savoir que Madame
Pécresse n'est pas très favorable à
cette disposition qu'en pensez-vous quel
est votre position monsieur
carochibe j'y suis totalement opposé je
trouve que c'est franchement
c'est c'est même presque un dessin un
million de véhicules utilisent le
périphérique tous les jours dont
seulement 15% de Parisiens et 40 à 50%
de banlieusards entre guillemets le
périphérique est bouché de manière
régulière avec toutes les voix
existantes imaginez ce que ça va être si
vous bloquez une voie de chaque côté à
partir de je ne sais quand après les les
Jeux Olympiques soit on trouve et on
développe les transports publics pour
qu'il y ait moins d'utilisation de
voitures soit on dégage d'autres accès
et là tant mieux mais pour le moment
pour le moment la circulation est-elle
sur le périphérique que dit on va
neutraliser une voie de chaque côté
c'est dire au million d'automobilistes
qui passent là mais seigneur merci pour
les bouchons vous allez pouvoir rester
bloqué sur le périphérique pollué autant
que vous voulez perdre des heures
franchement c'est pas descend attendons
de voir
lorsque le Grand Paris Express sera
terminé si les transports publics autour
de la capitale sont-elles que beaucoup
moins de gens utilisent leur véhicule et
à ce moment-là voyons ce que l'on peut
faire mais tant que ça n'est pas fait
franchement on ne met pas assez de
moyens pas plus la mairie de Paris que
l'État d'ailleurs on n'est pas assez de
moyens sur les transports publics et on
veut en parallèle geler une partie de la
capacité routière ça n'est pas correct
et c'est mettre la charrue avant les
bœufs
de gouvernance
que le la gestion du périphérique soit
transférée à la
IDFM vous êtes toujours sur cette
position vous n'avez pas obtenu gain de
cause à l'époque plus globalement il
vous semble que la région devrait
davantage qu'aujourd'hui être en
compétence sur l'ensemble des transports
je n'ai pas obtenu satisfaction mais
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas gagné
qu'on doit changer d'avis donc je n'ai
pas changé d'avis je considère que je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure le périphérique
15% de Parisiens pratiquement la moitié
des utilisateurs sont des banlieusards
le reste sont des provinciaux etc mais
ça veut dire que c'est un axe de
circulation qui est extraordinairement
utilisé par beaucoup de francilien non
parisiens laisser la maîtrise de ce
périphérique seulement à la mairie de
Paris quel que soit les qualités ou
défaut de la Mairie de Paris ça n'est
pas normal puisque en réalité les
utilisateurs sont beaucoup plus extra
parisiennes parisiens donc moi je
souhaite que la gestion du périphérique
dépend davantage de la région encore des
Nations avec la Mairie de Paris mais que
la région Île-de-France
IDFM est beaucoup plus les moyens
réellement de gérer ce périphérique oui
une question rapidement Jacques sur les
transports et le financement
oui vous l'avez
vous estimez que l'État ne met pas assez
au pot
genre Siffredi la répéter lors du
dernier lors de la dernière séance
plénière des Hauts-de-Seine vous estimez
que l'État doit davantage investir
n'est-ce pas vous avez raison dans la
plaie à l'excellence président du
conseil départemental des Hauts de cette
gentil Freddy
qu'est-ce qui se passe en vrai on a
besoin de plus en plus d'investissements
Grand Paris Express prolongation des
lignes de métro rallongement des lignes
de bus etc on a besoin de plus en plus
d'investissements et dans cette période
l'état nous dit si vous voulez des prêts
pas de souci mais si vous voulez des
investissements directs ah c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et on dit à la
région et aux collectivités le
département des Hauts-de-Seine
s'implique fortement dans les transports
publics on dit aux collectivités
débrouillez-vous mais débrouillez-vous
alors donnez-nous la maîtrise entière
moi si on nous dit par exemple sur le
Grand Paris Express vous trouverez
normal c'est c'est ce sont les
Franciliens qui payent qui payent
puisque c'est un une taxe supplémentaire
en réalité qui finance le Grand Paris
Express et c'est l'État qui Ana la
gestion pas la région pardon de vous
dire qui paye des sites alors si on veut
nous faire payer très bien on nous donne
la totalité de la décision
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci on
regarde la une journal du Grand Paris
Les Verts présentent le détail de
l'accord sur le plus bio climatique
c'est à la Une du journal du Grand Paris
merci beaucoup Jacques paquet d'avoir
été avec nous merci projet caoutchi
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin